ASSEMBLY MEMBER WHETHER NOTICES
THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM THE
SERGEANT AT ARMS WILL PREPARE
THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN THE
ABSENT MEMBERS TO THE FLOOR. THE
CLERK WILL CALL THE ROLL.
ACOSTA
AGUIAR-CURRY
ALLEN ARAMBULA.
BAKER. BERMAN.
BIGELOW BLOOM.
BONTA BROUGH.
BURKE
CABALLERO.
CALDERON CARILLO CERVANTES CHAU.
CHAVEZ
CHEN.
DAVID CHIU CHOI KANSEN CHU.
COOLEY
COOPER CUNNINGHAM DALLY.
DALY. EGGMAN FLORA.
FONG.
FRAZIER FRIEDMAN.
GALLAGHER CRISTINA GARCIA
EDUARDO GARCIA. GIPSON GLORIA
GONZALEZ FLETCHER. GRAY. GRAYSON
HARPER HOLDEN.
IRWIN JONES SAWYER. KALRA
KAMLAGER-DOVE KILEY. LACKEY
LEVINE. LIMON ALONE LOW.
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS
MAYES
MCCARTY MEDINA MELENDEZ MULLIN
MURATSUCHI NAZARIAN. OBERNOLTE
O'DONNELL PATTERSON QUIRK.
QUIRK SILVA REYES RODRIGUEZ
RUBIO SALAS SANTIAGO STEINORTH
STONE.
THURMOND.
TING VOEPEL WALDRON WEBER. WOOD
MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS
THE ASSEMBLY IS NOW IN SESSION.
A QUORUM IS NOW PRESENT WE ASK
OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS IN THE
REAR OF THE CHAMBER IN THE
GALLERY TO PLEASE STAND FOR
TODAY'S PRAYER. WHICH WILL BE
OFFERED BY OUR ASSEMBLY CHAPLAIN
HEADY OSHA.
RIVER NO STUFF.
AS WE LOOK FORWARD TO A LONG
WEEKEND HOME BEING WITH THOSE WE
LOVE.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN A MOMENT OF
REFLECTION.
LOUD SUE WAS AWARE OF THE
IMPORTANCE OF LOVE IN OUR LIVES.
HE SAID.
FROM BEING LOVED DEEPLY COMES
DURING.
FROM LOVING DEEPLY COMES
COURAGE.
NORMALLY GO SOON NURTURED BY
LOVE IN OUR LIVES LET US LIVE
WITH KINDNESS AND GRATITUDE
BEYOND WORDS.
AND BY YOU TO REMAIN STANDING
FOR THE FLAG SALUTE WHICH WILL
BE OFFERED TODAY BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WOULD.
MR WOULD.
THESE REPEAT AFTER ME.
I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG.
OPENING NIGHT.
AND TO THE REPUBLIC FOR WHICH IT
STANDS.
HAITIAN.
INDIVISIBLE WITH LIBERTY AND
JUSTICE PROBLEM.
YOU MAY BE SEATED.
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL ASSEMBLY CHAMBER
SACRAMENTO THURSDAY MAY TENTH
TWENTY EIGHTEEN EASILY MET AT
NINE A. M. UNTIL KEVIN MULLINS
SPEAKER PRO TEM OF THE FAMILY
PRESIDING CIRCLED AROUND MOVES
AND MR DAILY SECONDS OF THE
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL BE DISPENSED WITH.
PRESENTATIONS OF PETITIONS THERE
ARE NONE INTRODUCTION IN
REFERENCE A BILLS WILL BE
DEFERRED REPORTS OF COMMITTEES
WILL BE DIM RED AND AMENDMENTS
DEEMED ADOPTED. MESSAGE FROM THE
GOVERNOR THERE ARE NINE MESSAGES
FROM THE SENATE THERE ARE NONE
LIVING OUT EMOTIONS AND REBEL.
RESOLUTIONS
TODAY'S ABSENCES ARE ABSENT
TODAY FOR LEGISLATIVE THIS
BUSINESS ASSEMBLY MEMBER WALKING
AROUND A LOT ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MARK LEVIN FOR PERSONAL BUSINESS
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BILL BOROUGH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MARK STEYN
WORTH.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MARIE WALTON.
MR COUNTER ON YOUR RECOGNIZED
YOUR MOTIONS THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT SUSPEND ITS ONLY ONE
EIGHTEEN NATO ALLOW SOME.
A PAL THAT GETS A PHOTOGRAPHER
THE FLOOR TODAY THEIR GUESTS
WILL BE SEATED AT HER DESK
WITHOUT OBJECTIONS
SHALL BE THE ORDER I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENSUS MEDICINE WE
WILL FORTY FIVE POINT FIVE AND
ALLOW US TO MEMBERS BLOOM FAWN
GALLAGHER MELINDA'S IT'S ALSO
SPEAK.
GERMAN IN MEMORY TODAY WITHOUT
OBJECTION
SHALL BE THE ORDER.
I MOVE TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY WILL
SIXTY THREE TO ALLOW ALL BILLS
HER TODAY FRIDAY MAY TWENTY
FIFTH TWENTY EIGHTEEN REPORT TO
THE DESK AND TODAY FRIDAY MAY
TWENTY FIFTH TWENTY EIGHTEEN.
TUESDAY MAY TWENTY NINE TWENTY
EIGHTEEN ARE WEDNESDAY MAY
THIRTIETH TWENTY EIGHTEEN FROM
THE PROCREATION IS COMMITTED TO
BE ORDERED TO THE SECOND OR
THIRD READING FILE. OR TO THAT
FIRST DAY CONSENT CALENDAR ONE
LEGISLATIVE DAY PRIOR TO THE DAY
REQUIRED UNDER THE ASSEMBLY
RULES.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER I MOVE TO SUSPEND.
JOINT RULES TWENTY EIGHT TWENTY
EIGHT POINT ONE IN TWENTY NINE
TO PERMIT IT THE APPOINTMENT OF
FIVE CONFEREES.
TO THE CONFERENCE COMMITTEE ON
SB EIGHT FORTY RELATING TO
BUDGET ACT TWENTY EIGHTEEN
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER.
I'M SORRY.
MEMBERS THE LAST MOTION REQUIRES
A ROLL CALL VOTE. MADAM CLERK
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE?
MR CALDERON IS REQUESTING AND I
VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE?
THIS IS FOR BUDGET CONSCIOUS.
THIS IS FOR BUDGET CONFEREES
MEMBERS ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE.
MADAM CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLE AND TALLY THE VOTES.
HIGHS FIFTY NINE NO ZERO.
THE MEASURE PASSES. THE RULES
ARE SUSPENDED.
TO COUNTER AND. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER OUT THE WEEK REQUEST OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER DOLLY PLEASE
REMOVE ITEM ONE OF SEVEN EIGHT.
TWENTY SEVEN THIRTY TWO IT'S
ALSO FLETCHER FROM.
THE CLERK WILL KNOW.
I REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
WAIVE JOIN RULE SIXTY TWO WAY
THE FILE NOTICE REQUIREMENT TO
HEAR THE FOLLOWING BILLS ON THE
SUSPENSE FILED. AND
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE TODAY
UPON ADJOURNMENT OF SESSION IN
ROOM.
FORTY TWO OH TO THE CLERK READ.
MADAM CLERK.
PLEASE READ.
A CYCLE SEVENTEEN THIRTY FOUR BY
THREE NUMBER CALLED AROUND
SEVENTEEN SIXTY FIVE BY SOME
REMEMBER QUICKSILVER AT NINETEEN
FIFTY SIX BY SELLING THE REAL
AMOUNT. NINETEEN FIFTY SEVEN BY
SAMANTHA BERMAN NINETEEN NINETY
BASICALLY MEMBER MATHIS TWENTY
YOU BASICALLY HAVE A COPIER.
TWENTY SIXTY SIX BY SOME HAMMER
MARKS DOWN TWENTY ONE ELEVEN BY
SOME MEMBER COURT TWENTY ONE
THIRTY EIGHT BY SILLY NUMBER TWO
TWO AND ONE EIGHTY THREE BY SOME
A MEMBER RUBIO TWENTY ONE EIGHTY
EIGHT BY THIRTY MEMBER MULLEN
TWENTY TWO ELEVEN BY SOME A
MEMBER OF THE MOUND. TWENTY
SEVENTEEN BY SOME A MEMBER BACK
TWENTY THIRTY FIVE BY SOME A
MEMBER QUICKSILVER TWENTY FIFTY
NINE BY SOME A MEMBER PATTERSON
TWENTY TWO NINETY TWO BY
SEPTEMBER AND WE ARE CURRY.
TWENTY THREE TWELVE BY SOME THE
MEMBER EDUARDO CURRY TWENTY
THREE TWENTY SIX BISON ARE
RUBIO.
TWENTY THREE THIRTY ONE BY SOME
A MEMBER WEBER TWENTY FOUR
THIRTY BY SIMPLY MERIMBULA
TWENTY FOUR FIFTY NINE BY SEVEN
MEMBER FRIEDMAN TWENTY FOUR
SEVENTY FOUR BY THREE MEMBER
COURT TWENTY FIVE SIXTY FIVE BY
SOME THE NUMBER TWO TWENTY FIVE
TWENTY FOUR BY SEVEN MEMBER
BLOOM. PLAY VIBES I MEAN I
BASICALLY MEMBER BURKE.
TWENTY SIX TWENTY SIX BY SOMEONE
EVER MULLEN TWENTY SIX THIRTY
SEVEN BY SOME THE MARROW DONALD
ME SIX EIGHTY TWO BY SLIMMER
BURKE TOOK TWENTY SEVEN HUNDRED
BY SOME MEMBER BURKE. TWENTY
SEVEN EIGHTEEN BY SOME A MEMBER
FRIEDMAN TWENTY SEVEN THIRTY
SEVEN BY SOME IN IRAQ WHERE
CURRY TWENTY EIGHT SIXTY ONE BY
SOME A MEMBER SOLITARY NINE
TWENTY THREE BY SLIMMER CHOOSE
ME NINE THIRTY TWO BY SONY
MEMBER TOY TRAIN NINE THIRTY SIX
BYTES OF THE MAN IS AREA. POINT
I'M FORTY FIVE BY SUMMER
GALLAGHER ME NINE SIXTY FIVE BY
SILLY MEMBER RANDY LET THIRTY
FIFTEEN BY SONY MEMBER COPY ERA.
THIRTY TWENTY NINE BY SILLY
MERIMBULA THIRTY THIRTY THREE BY
SOME INNER MEANTIME THIRTY
THIRTY SEVEN BY SUMMER DAVID
TWO.
THIRTY THIRTY NINE BY THREE
MEMBER HOLDING THIRTY SEVENTY
TWO BY SOME A MEMBER DAVID TO
THIRTY EIGHTY SEVEN BY SELLING
OUR CLUB AT THIRTY ONE TWENTY BY
SOME AMERICANS ALSO LEDGER.
THIRTY ONE FORTY SEVEN BY
SLAYING ARCHIVIO THIRTY ONE
FORTY EIGHT BY SLIMMER AROUND
THE LETTER YOU ONCE EVERY SIX BY
SLIMMER WALDRON AND THIRTY ONE
NINETY SEVEN BY SOMETHING NEVER
WORK. WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH
SHELBY OR THE ORDER MEMBERS WE
ARE MOVING NOW TO BUSINESS ON
THE DAILY FILE.
MEMBERS.
I CAN HAVE YOUR ATTENTION WE
HAVE A SPECIAL GUEST WITH US
HERE TODAY IN THE CHAMBERS.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BILL PELL YOUR
RECOGNIZE
OUR GUEST.
MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS YEARS
DIFFERENCE IN OUR AGES
I'M THE OLDER BROTHER SEES THE
BABY OF THE FAMILY.
AND YES SHE WAS NAMED BY OUR
FATHER AFTER A PIPER CUB
AIRCRAFT.
AND LUCKILY MY MOTHER NAMED ME
OTHERWISE I COULD HAVE BEEN BOW
WE ARE GROWN MEN ARE BEING FIFTY
TWO.
THANK YOU.
WELCOME.
MADAM CLERK WE PLEASE READ THE
SECOND READING OF BILLS.
AS SOME PEOPLE TWENTY SEVEN
SEVENTY SEVEN.
ALL BILLS HAVE BEEN DEEMED RED
AND AMENDMENTS ADOPTED.
CONTINUING A BUSINESS ON THE
DAILY FILE FILE ITEMS TO.
THROUGH TWELVE.
SORRY FILE ITEMS TWO THROUGH
FOUR.
WILL BE CONTINUED FILE ITEMS.
SEVEN THROUGH TWELVE PASSING
RETAIN.
MOVING OUT ITEM THIRTEEN AB
TWENTY NINETY NINE MADAM CLERK
PLEASE READ. AS A LEGAL TWENTY
NINETY NINE WITH AMENDMENTS BY
SOME REMEMBER GLORIA.
MEMBERS WE HAVE BUSINESS ON THE
FLOOR PLEASE GIVE YOUR ATTENTION
TO MR GLORIA SOMEONE MEMBER
GLORIA YOU'RE RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER THIS IS A
TECHNICAL AMENDMENT THE CORRECTS
A.
DRAFTING AIR COMING OUT OF
POLICY COMMITTEE I RESPECTFULLY
ASK WHEN I VOTE ON THIS
AMENDMENT.
THANK YOU WITHOUT OBJECTION WILL
TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THE
AMENDMENT
ALL THOSE IN FAVOR SIGNIFY BY
SAYING AYE.
ALL THOSE OPPOSED.
THE AMENDMENTS ARE ADOPTED.
THE BILL IS OUT OF PRINT AND
BACK ON FILE. ITEM FOURTEEN AB
TWENTY SEVEN SEVENTY NINE MADAM
CLERK PLEASE READ.
AS SOME PEOPLE TWENTY SEVEN
SEVENTY NINE WITH AMENDMENTS BY
SUMMING UP REMARKS DOWN SOME
REMEMBER STONE YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS THESE AMENDMENTS APPLY
THE BILL ONLY TWO WATER BOTTLES
AND EXEMPT SMALL BOTTLERS THIS
IS THE BILL THAT WOULD REQUIRE.
SINGLE USE PLASTIC BOTTLES TO BE
HAD THE LEADS AT LEAST TO THEM I
RESPECTFULLY ASK CAN I VOTE ON
THE AMENDMENT TO THE BILL GO OUT
TO PRINT BE PUT BACK ON FIVE.
THANK YOU WITHOUT OBJECTION WE
WILL TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THE
AMENDMENTS ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SIGNIFY BY SAYING AYE.
ALL THOSE OPPOSED.
THE AMENDMENTS ARE ADOPTED THE
BILL IS OUT OF PRINT AND BACK ON
FILE.
ITEMS FIFTEEN THROUGH TWENTY
THREE. PASSIN RETAIN ITEM TWENTY
FOUR AB TWENTY THREE NINETY TWO
MADAM CLERK PLEASE READ AS SOME
PEOPLE TWENTY THREE NINETY TWO
WITH THE MAMMOTH BY SOME THE
MEMBER SANTIAGO.
SOME NEVER SANTIAGO YOUR
RECOGNIZE A THINKING MAN'S
SPEAKER. OF THE BILL IS UP FOR
AMENDMENTS AMENDMENTS ARE CLEAR
FIND TECHNICAL AND JUST THINK.
CERN'S I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR.
WITHOUT OBJECTION WILL TAKE A
VOICE VOTE ON THE AMENDMENTS ALL
THOSE IN FAVOR PLEASE SIGNIFY BY
SAYING AYE.
ALL THOSE OPPOSED.
SIGNIFY.
THE AMENDMENTS ARE ADOPTED THE
BILL IS OUT OF PRINT AND BACK ON
FILE.
ITEMS TWENTY FIVE.
THROUGH THIRTY TWO ARE PASSING
RETAIN ITEM THIRTY THREE AB
THIRTY ONE THIRTY EIGHT.
MEMBERS.
PLEASE GIVE YOUR ATTENTION TO A
TO THIS NEXT MEMBER MADAM CLERK
PLEASE READ. THE LEGAL THIRTY
ONE THIRTY EIGHT WITH THE MEMONS
BY SOMETHING I MURMURS DIGI.
SOME NEVER SEARCH YOUR
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS AB THIRTY
ONE THIRTY EIGHT. AND FORCES
STRICTER PENALTIES ON FACILITIES
THAT HANDLE HIGHLY TOXIC OR
FLAMMABLE CHEMICALS.
TO PREVENT ACCIDENTS THAT MIGHT
POSE SERIOUS RISKS TO THE PUBLIC
AND THE ENVIRONMENT. THESE
AMENDMENTS NEGOTIATED WITH THE
INDUSTRY WILL REMOVE ALL
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL OF RIGHTS
RESPECTFULLY REQUESTS HAVE BEEN
HAS BEEN ADOPTED IN THE BELL GO
OUT TO PRINT. AND BACK ON FILE
THANK YOU WITHOUT OBJECTION WE
WILL TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THE
ITEM.
ALL THOSE IN FAVOR SIGNIFY BY
SAYING AYE.
ALL THOSE OPPOSED.
THE AMENDMENTS ARE ADOPTED THE
BILL IS OUT OF PRINT AND BACK ON
FILE.
NEXT WE WILL VOTE ON LAUREL
VERSES YANDY.
THAT GOT YOUR ATTENTION.
ITEMS THIRTY FOUR THIRTY THIRTY
FIVE PASSING RETAIN ITEM THIRTY
SIX
MADAM CLERK PLEASE READ.
AT SOME LEGAL SEVENTEEN SIXTY
ONE WITH AMENDMENTS BY FAMILY
MEMBERS WHO CHEAT.
SOME REMEMBER MERCER TO YOUR
RECOGNIZE THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER FOR GETTING EVERYONE'S
ATTENTION AB SEVENTEEN SIXTY ONE
THE HOTEL HOUSEKEEPER PROTECTION
ACT. PROTECTS HOTEL EMPLOYEES
FROM SEXUAL ASSAULT AND
HARASSMENT FROM HOTEL GAS.
THESE AMENDMENTS ADDRESS
CONCERNS REGARDING THE REPORTING
OF INCIDENTS TO LAW ENFORCEMENT
INCLUDE THE PENALTIES FOR THE
SPELL I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
THAT MEMBERS BE ADOPTED THE BELL
GO OUT PRINTER BACK ON FILE.
THANK YOU WITHOUT OBJECTION WILL
TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THE ITEM
ALL THOSE IN FAVOR SIGNIFY BY
SAYING AYE.
ALL THOSE OPPOSED.
THE AMENDMENTS ARE ADOPTED THE
BILL IS OUT OF PRINT AND BACK ON
FILE.
ITEMS THIRTY SEVEN THROUGH FORTY
ONE PASS AND RETAIN THAT ITEM
FORTY TWO PAST TEMPORARILY ITEMS
FORTY THREE THROUGH FORTY FIVE
PAST.
PAIN MOVING OUT ITEM FORTY SIX
AB TWENTY FOUR EIGHTY FIVE MADAM
CLERK PLEASE READ.
AS A LEGAL TWENTY FOUR EIGHTY
FIVE WITH AMENDMENTS BY SOME THE
MEMBER CHILD.
SUMMER TELL YOU'RE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MADAM SPEAKER AND MEMBERS SOME
PRESENTING AMENDMENTS TO AB
TWENTY FOUR EIGHTY FIVE THE
AMENDMENTS WERE MADE TO REMOVE
THE OPPOSITION OF ODD ROLE
COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIA WITHOUT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOU RIGHT NOW.
THANK YOU WITHOUT OBJECTION WILL
TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THE
AMENDMENTS ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SIGNIFY BY SAYING.
ALL THOSE OPPOSED.
THE AMENDMENTS ARE ADOPTED THE
BILL IS OUT OF PRINT IMPACT ON
FILE MOVING NOW TO ITEM FORTY
SEVEN E. B. TWENTY FIVE FIFTY
EIGHT HELP.
MADAM CLERK PLEASE READ.
SOME PEOPLE TWENTY FIVE FIFTY
EIGHT WITH THE MEN.
BRO.
THANK YOU I SOME MEMORY LACKEY
YOU'LL BE TAKING UP THE
AMENDMENTS YOUR RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I RISE
TO PRESENT AMENDMENTS TO AB
TWENTY FIVE FIFTY EIGHT.
TWENTY FIVE FIFTY EIGHT WILL
ESTABLISH CLEAR PROCEDURES TO
FOLLOW WHEN A LOCAL GOVERNMENT
SEEKS TO CONSOLIDATE THE ELECTED
POSITIONS.
OF THE COUNTY AUDITOR CONTROLLER
AND TREASURER TAX COLLECTOR.
MEMBERS OF THESE AMENDMENTS ARE
CLEAN UP CHANGES FOR CONSISTENCY
IN THE BUILD A HOUSE FOR YOUR
EYE.
A VOTE ON THESE AMENDMENTS THANK
YOU THANK YOU WITHOUT OBJECTION
WE WILL TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THE
AMENDMENTS ALL THOSE.
IN FAVOR SIGNIFY BY SAYING AYE.
ALL THOSE OPPOSED.
THE AMENDMENTS ARE ADOPTED THE
BILL IS OUT OF PRINT IMPACT ON
FILE.
ITEMS FORTY EIGHT FORTY NINE
PASS AND RETAIN ITEM FIFTY PAST
TEMPORARILY.
ITEM FIFTY ONE PASS AND RETAIN
ITEM FIFTY TWO AB TWENTY ONE OH
SEVEN MADAM CLERK PLEASE READ.
SOME LEGAL TWENTY ONE OH SEVEN
WITH AMENDMENTS BY SOME THE
MEMORY IS.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAY AS YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED FOR THE AMENDMENTS
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
I RISE TO PRESENT AMENDMENTS ON
AB TWENTY ONE OH SEVEN RELATED
TO MOTOR VEHICLE. FRANCHISE
AGREEMENTS
THE AMENDMENTS REPRESENT OUR
WORK WITH SOME OPPONENTS
TO WORK ALL WORK OUT
TECHNOLOGICAL INNOVATION ISSUES.
AND WITH THESE AMENDMENTS THOSE
ISSUES ARE RESOLVED IN ADDITION
THE AMENDMENTS ADDRESS SEVERAL
IMPORTANT ISSUES THAT HAVE COME
UP.
IN DISCUSSIONS WITH STAKEHOLDERS
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOU I
VOTE ON THE AMENDMENTS.
MEMBERS I NEED TO BE ABLE TO
HEAR THE VOTE. WITHOUT OBJECTION
WILL TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THE
AMENDMENTS ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SIGNIFY BY SAYING AYE.
ALL THOSE OPPOSED.
THE AMENDMENTS ARE ADOPTED THE
BILL IS.
OUT TO PRINT AND BACK ON FILE.
ITEM FIFTY THREE THROUGH SIXTY
ONE PASSIN RETAIN.
ITEMS.
SIXTY TWO AND SIXTY THREE PAST
TEMPORARILY ITEM SIXTY FOUR TO
SEVENTY TWO.
PASSING RETAIN
MOVING BACK AND FOUGHT BACK IN
ORDER TO ITEM FIFTY EIGHT AB
TWENTY SEVEN FORTY SIX MADAM
CLERK PLEASE READ. AT SOME LEGAL
TO HUNT TWENTY SEVEN FORTY SIX
BY SOME A MEMBER EDUARDO GARCIA
AND ACTUALLY TO TAXATION.
AS A MEMBER GARCIA YOUR
RECOGNIZE.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES AB TWENTY SIX SEVEN
FORTY SIX CLARIFIES THE STATE'S
INTENT OF LAW. BY ENABLING
TREASURER TAX COLLECTORS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE TO CONTINUE
THERE'S TAX SALES PROCESS
WITHOUT BEING IMPAIRED IF A
BANKRUPTCY IS FILED AFTER THE
RIGHT. OF REDEMPTION HAS EXPIRED
THERE'S THE NEED TO CLARIFY SOME
AREAS OF THE LAW THERE'S BEEN A
LACK OF CLARITY IN THE STATE.
LAW THAT OPEN THE DOOR FOR
ABUSIVE PROVISIONING CAUSES
ADDITIONAL PROBLEMS FOR MULTI
DAY TAX BILLS CONDUCTED BY VIA
THE INTERNET.
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL.
THANK YOU SEE NO FURTHER SEEING
NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE MADAM
CLERK PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL-ON.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
MADAM CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLLING TALLY THE VOTES.
EYES SIXTY TWO KNOWS ONE THE
MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING NOW BACK IN FILE ORDER.
ITEM FORTY TWO AB TWENTY THREE
FIFTY THREE. MADAM CLERK PLEASE
READ. AT SOME LEVEL TWENTY THREE
FIFTY THREE BY SOME REMEMBER
FRASIER AND ACTUALLY THE
CONSTRUCTION DEFECTS.
THANK YOU AS I REMEMBER FRASIER
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER AND MEMBERS.
I RISE TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY THREE FIFTY THREE. TO
REQUIRE INSPECTORS OF
CONSTRUCTION DEFECT CLAIMS TO BE
LICENSED BY THE CONTRACTOR
STRAIGHT STATE LICENSED BOARD.
OUR CONSTRUCTION DEFECT LAWS
WERE HEAVILY NEGOTIATED WELL
OVER A DECADE AGO. AND OVER THIS
OVER THE SAME TIME SINCE
SHORTFALLS HAVE EMERGED.
SIGNIFICANT PROBLEMS STEM FROM
THOSE WHO ABUSE THE SYSTEM TO
MAKE A QUICK BUCK.
THE UNNECESSARY LONG STATUTE OF
LIMITATION UP TO TEN YEARS.
LEAD MANY TO FILE CLAIMS WITHIN
THE LAST FEW MONTHS OF THE
LIMIT.
IN FILING A CLAIM CONSTRUCTION
DEFECT PROCESSES DO NOT REQUIRE
CLAIMANTS.
APPROVE ANY DAMAGE AND MANY
TIMES WILL BRING LA UNLICENSED
INSPECTORS.
TO CONDUCT THE DESTRUCTIVE
TESTING.
THESE CLAIMS BECAUSE BUILDERS
COUNTLESS HOURS AND DOLLARS TO
CORRECT. MONEY IN TIME THAT
WOULD OTHERWISE GO TOWARD
CLOSING.
CALIFORNIA'S HUGE HOUSING
AFFORDABLE GAP.
MEMBERS THIS IS AN INCREMENTAL
CHANGE THAT WOULD HELP STEM
ABUSIVELY THE LITIGATION.
STRENGTHEN THE INTENT OF THE
STATE'S CONSTRUCTION DEFECT
BECAUSE.
THANK YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST DRIVE VOTE.
THANK YOU MR FRASER SEEN NO
OTHER MEMBERS WISHING TO SPEAK
ON THIS ITEM AND ASK THE CLERK
TO PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL-ON.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
CLICK A CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY
THE VOTES I SIXTY SEVEN KNOWS
ZERO THAT.
MEASURE PASSES.
THAT BRINGS US TO HAVE FILE ITEM
NUMBER FIFTY.
COOKERY.
SOME EVIL THIRTY ONE SIXTY TWO
BY FAMILY MEMBER FRIEDMAN AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY THE
ALCOHOLISM OR DRUG ABUSE
CEMENT NEVER FRIEDMAN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISS THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS AB THIRTY
ONE SIXTY TWO IS A TECHNICAL
CLEAN UP BILL TO HELP THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES. MORE EFFECTIVELY
ADMINISTER AND MANAGE THE STATE
ISSUANCE OF LICENSES FOR
RESIDENTIAL ALCOHOL AND DRUG
ABUSE TREATMENT FACILITIES WITH
CAPACITY OF SIX OR LESS PERSONS.
WE REQUESTED AND RECEIVED
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE FROM
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES AND THE DEPARTMENT
PROVIDED THE LANGUAGE FOR A. B.
THIRTY ONE SIXTY TWO WHICH
PROVIDES THE NEEDED LEGISLATIVE
AUTHORITY. TO ENSURE THAT
SERVICES UNDER RESIDENTIAL
LICENSE ARE PROVIDED SOLELY AT
THE LOCATION WHERE THE STATE
LICENSES ISSUED. INCLUDE A
PROVISIONAL ONE YEAR INITIAL
PROBATIONARY PERIOD PROVIDE
NOTIFICATION OF ISSUANCE OF
LICENSES UPDATE FINES TO ENSURE
COMPLIANCE.
IT IS SUPPORTED BY THE LEAGUE OF
CALIFORNIA CITIES CALIFORNIA
CONTRACT CITIES ASSOCIATIONS AND
CITIES UP AND DOWN THE STATE.
IT IS RECEIVED BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT AND NO NO VOTES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK HERE I VOTE.
THANK YOU SIMON NUMBER FREDMAN
SEEN OTHER MEMBERS WISHING TO
SPEAK ON THIS ITEM CLICK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
CLICK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE AND
TALLY THE VOTES I SIXTY FOUR
KNOWS ZERO. THAT MOTION THAT
MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS UNDER ANNOUNCEMENTS.
MISTER CUNNINGHAM YOU HAVE A
SPECIAL GUEST WITH YOU ON THE
FLOOR.
THANK YOU MR SPEAKER MEMBERS I'M
PLEASED TO WELCOME TO THE FLOOR
AND HAVE WITH ME TODAY. MY SON
TYLER.
TOOK A BREAK OUT OF THE SOCCER
BASEBALL SCHOOL IN CHESS CLUB
SCHEDULED TO COME JOIN US.
AND WILL BE HEADING FROM HERE
TO.
PRESIDENT FOR BASEBALL
TOURNAMENT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WELCOME.
MOVING NOW TO ITEM SIXTY TWO A
B. TWENTY EIGHT SIXTY THREE
MADAM CLERK PLEASE READ AT SOME
LEVEL TWENTY EIGHT SIXTY THREE
BY SOME A MEMBER IN THIS AREA
AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY TO HELP.
COVERAGE.
THANK YOU WITH SOME REMEMBER HIS
ARYAN. THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER
AND COLLEAGUES AB TWENTY EIGHT
SIXTY THREE WILL ALLOW
PHARMACISTS TO CHARGE CONSUMERS
THE LOWEST AVAILABLE COSTS FOR
THEIR PRESCRIPTIONS. WHETHER
THIS IS THE CO PAY NEGOTIATED BY
THEIR HEALTH PLAN OR THE RETAIL
PRICE.
IT ALSO REQUIRES THE SUBMITTED
CHARGES UP WHEN CASH IS USED FOR
THE RETAIL PRICE.
BE APPLIED TO CONSUMERS THE
DEDUCTIBLE AND OUT OF POCKET
MAXIMUM AS IF THE HEALTH
BENEFITS WAS USE.
IT HAS NO OPPOSITION AND HAS
RECEIVED NO NO VOTES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK VERY I VOTE.
MADAM CLERK PLEASE OPEN THE
ROLL-ON ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERSVOTE WHO DESIRE TO
MADAM CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLE AND TALLY THE VOTES.
EYES FIFTY SEVEN NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING OUT ITEM SIXTY THREE AB
SEVENTEEN SEVENTY THREE MADAM
CLERK PLEASE READ. AT SOME LEVEL
SEVENTEEN SEVENTY THREE BY THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS AND
EXPLAINED PAYMENT CLAIMS AGAINST
THE STATE MAKING A PREPARATION
THEREFORE DECRYING THE URGENCY
THERE UP TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY. THANK YOU WITH SOME
AMERICANS ALWAYS FLETCHER YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED.
THINK YOU AB SEVENTEEN SEVENTY
THREE IS WHEN THE BILLS REQUIRED
TO BE BROUGHT FORWARD BY THE
PREPARATIONS COMMITTEE WHICH
APPROPRIATES MONEY FOR APPROVED
LEGAL SETTLEMENTS THIS BILL
SPECIFICALLY APPROPRIATES ELEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS IN ONE TIME
FUNDING FOR THREE COURT CASES.
HE'S BEEN APPROVED BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE AND
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR IVA.
THANK YOU MADAM CLERK PLEASE
OPEN.
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL-ON.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
VOTE
.
BUT A QUICK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROWING TALLY THE VOTES EYES
FIFTY NINE NO ZERO ON THE
URGENCY.
EYES FIFTY NINE NO ZERO ON THE
MEASURE THE MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING NOW TO ITEM SEVENTY THREE
EIGHTY TWENTY EIGHT FORTY NINE
MADAM CLERK PLEASE READ.
AT SOME LEVEL TWENTY EIGHT FORTY
NINE BY SUMMING UP REMARKS DOWN
AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY THE
RESOURCE CONSERVATION.
THANK YOU SO MEMBER STONE YOUR
RECOGNIZE F YOU MADAM SPEAKER
MEMBERS ON BEHALF OF MYSELF AND
MY JOINT AUTHOR OUR COLLEAGUE
FROM BEAVER I'D LIKE TO PRESENT.
THIS BILL WAGE UPDATES SOME OF
THE LAWS AROUND THE SIERRA
NEVADA CONSERVANCY CONCERTS HE
WAS ESTABLISHED TO HELP PROTECT
AND MANAGE FORESTS IN THE SIERRA
NEVADA. WHAT THIS BILL DOES IS
PUT IN STATUTE THE WATERSHED
IMPROVEMENT PROGRAM THAT THEY
HAVE MAKE SOME CHANGES TO THEIR
GOVERNANCE AND CLARIFIES THE
DEFINITIONS OF TRIBES TO ENSURE
THE CALIFORNIA TRIBES CAN BE
INCLUDED? IN THE GRANTS THAT ARE
BEING MADE HERE I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR I. VOTES.
THANK YOU SEE NO REQUEST TO
SPEAK MADAM CLERK PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLL-ON.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MADAM CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLE AND TALLY THE VOTES.
I WAS FIFTY NINE NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING NOW TO ITEM SEVENTY FOUR
AB TWENTY EIGHT SEVENTY THREE
MADAM CLERK PLEASE READ.
AT SOME LEVEL TWENTY EIGHT
SEVENTY THREE BY SOMETHING
NUMBER LOW AND ACTUALLY THE
PERSONAL VEHICLE SHARING.
THANK YOU SO MEMBER LOW YOUR
RECOGNIZE THAT YOU VERY MUCH
MADAM SPEAKER AND MEMBERS AB
TWENTY EIGHT SEVENTY THREE
SIMPLY EXPANDS EXISTING SAFETY
PROTECTIONS. IN FEDERAL AND
STATE LAWS THAT APPLY TO RECORD
RENTAL CAR COMPANIES REGARDING
PERFORMANCE OF SAFETY RECALLS TO
INCLUDE PERSONAL VEHICLE
SHARING.
PROGRAMS I'D SIMPLY PUT IT ADDS
ADS CONSUMER PROTECTIONS OUT
WITHIN OF THIS INDUSTRY AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK DR.
THANK YOUS
SEEING NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
MADAM CLERK PLEASE OPEN THE
WRONG.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MADAM CLERK.
PLEASE CLOSE THE ROLE TALLY THE
VOTES.
EYES FIFTY FOUR NOSE TO THE
MEASURE PASSES
.
MOVING OUR CONSENT HOW ANY
MEMBER WISH TO REMOVE AN
ITEM FROM THE CONCERT.
UNDER.
SEEING AND HEARING ON THE CLERK
WILL READ THE SECOND THEY
CONSENT CALENDAR AS THE LEGAL
TWENTY EIGHT TWENTY SIX BY SOME
REMEMBER FRIEDMAN AND ACTUALLY
THE PEOPLE ENROLLMENT.
THANK YOU MADAM CLERK WILL YOU
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL-ON THOSE
VOTES. MEMBERS ALL THOSE VOTE
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL THOSE VOTING ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR PLEASE VOTE.
IF YOU DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MEDICALLY PLEASE CLOSE THE REAL
ANTALYA THE VOTES I SIXTY THREE
KNOWS ZERO THE CONSENT CALENDAR
IS ADOPTED.
THE REMAINING ITEMS WILL BE
DEFERRED UNTIL ADJOURNMENT.
MEMBERS I'M ORDERING THE DEATHS
TO BE HELD OPEN TONIGHT AND ON
SATURDAY TO PROCESS
APPROPRIATION CAN
PORTS.
MEMBERS THE IF I HAVE SOME WE
APPROPRIATIONS HEARING WILL BE
HELD IN ROOM FORTY TWO OH TWO
UPON ADJOURNMENT UPON
ADJOURNMENT ALL MEMBERS OF THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE ARE TO
REPORT IMMEDIATELY.
A FORTY TWO OH TWO.
THE SESSION SCHEDULE IS AS
FOLLOWS MONDAY MAY TWENTY EIGHTH
HOLIDAY MEMORIAL DAY TUESDAY MAY
TWENTY NINTH FLOOR SESSION FROM
ONE PM TO SEE
PM.
IN THE ABSENCE OF OBJECTION THE
QUORUM CALLS LIFTED AND WE WILL
NOW MOVE TO PREVIOUSLY ANNOUNCED
THE GERMANS IN MEMORY.
THE FOLLOWING MEMBERS WERE
GRANTED PRIOR PERMISSION TO
SPEAK ON A GERMAN IN MEMORY.
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS
TAKE YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF THE
FOUR OR IF YOU'RE ON
APPROPRIATIONS PLEASE REPORT
IMMEDIATELY TO FORTY TWO OH TWO
VERY GOOD MEMBERS ON A GERMANS
A WILL BEGIN STARTING. THIS
MORNING WITH A MISTER BLOOM MR
THEM YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
GERMAN IN MEMORY.
THANK YOU MR SPEAKER MEMBERS I
RISE TO ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY OF
CELEBRATED FILM EDITOR AND V.
COATS.
OVER HER SIXTY YEAR CAREER IN
THE FILM INDUSTRY COATS EDITED
OVER FIFTY MOVIES AND BROUGHT
HER UNIQUE VISION TO PROMINENT
FILMS SUCH AS.
LAWRENCE OF ARABIA AND THE
ELEPHANT MAN.
COACH WAS BORN IN NINETEEN
TWENTY FIVE IN ENGLAND AND FELL
IN LOVE WITH MOVIES AFTER
WATCHING WITHERING HEIGHTS IN
NINETEEN THIRTY NINE. AND SHE
SET HER SIGHTS ON A CAREER IN
WHAT WAS THEN AN ALL MALE
INDUSTRY.
BUT AFTER BRIEFLY WORKING AS A
NURSE SHE GOT HER BREAK INTO THE
INDUSTRY WHEN SHE WAS HIRED BY
HER UNCLE'S FILM STUDIO. TO HELP
MAKE RELIGIOUS VIDEOS KNOWN IS
AT AT THAT TIME THEY WERE CALLED
SUNDAY SHORTS.
COACH WORKED HER WAY UP FROM
BEING AN APPRENTICE TO CUT IT
TOO WELL CUTTING ROOM ASSISTANT
BEFORE BECOMING AN ASSISTANT
EDITOR AT PINEWOOD STUDIOS IN
ENGLAND. BUT EVENTUALLY MADE HER
WAY TO HOLLYWOOD SETTLING IN
CALIFORNIA IN THE NINETEEN
EIGHTIES.
COACH HAD A HAND IN EDITING OVER
FIFTY FILMS DURING HER CAREER
INCLUDING MURDER ON THE ORIENT
EXPRESS.
ERIN BROCKOVICH
AND AS I SAID BEFORE THE
ELEPHANT MAN BUT SHE IS PERHAPS
BEST KNOWN FOR HER WORK ON THE
CLASSIC FILM LAWRENCE OF ARABIA
FOR WHICH SHE WON. AN ACADEMY
AWARD FOR BEST ADDING EDITING.
COACH WAS NOMINATED FOR FOUR
OTHER ACADEMY AWARDS OVER HER
CAREER AS WELL AS FOR A BAFTA
HAS.
AND COACH BROKE THROUGH BARRIERS
SHE THRIVED IN A WORLD WHERE.
IN TWO THOUGHT AS RECENTLY AS
TWO THOUSAND FOUR. WOMEN
ACCOUNTED FOR ONLY SIXTEEN
PERCENT OF ALL EDITORS AND
EIGHTY PERCENT OF EDITING TEAMS
HAD NO FEMALES AT ALL.
COACH NEVER RETIRED WORKING INTO
HER NINETIES BEFORE SHE PASSED
AWAY ON MAY EIGHTH AT THE AGE OF
NINETY TWO. AND IS SURVIVED BY
HER DAUGHTER EMMA A FILM EDITOR
ALSO AND SONS ANTHONY AND JAMES
BOTH DIRECTORS AND I ASK THAT WE
ADJOURN IN HER MEMORY.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER BLOOM.
AS A MEMBER OF A FUNK YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
I THANK YOU MR SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I RISE TODAY TO JR IN
THE MEMORY OF FORMER BIGGEST AND
MAYOR.
HARVEY HALL WHO PASSED AWAY AT
THE AGE OF THIRTY SEVEN MAYOR
HOW WAS THE LONGEST SERVING
MAYOR AND BIGGEST OF HISTORY.
THE FOUNDER OF HALL AMBULANCE
SERVICE INCORPORATED A TRULY
UNFORGETTABLE MEMBER OF OUR
COMMUNITY.
DURING A SIXTEEN YEARS AS MAYOR
MR HALL COMBATED.
OUR OUR HOMELESS THIS PROBLEM
INVESTED IN THE COMMUNITIES USE
AND ESTABLISH MEANINGFUL
RELATIONSHIPS WITH OUR SISTER
CITIES.
HE SURE IS DEDICATION TO THE
SUCCESS OF THE BAGS OF YOUTH BY
DONATING HIS ENTIRE SALARY TO
COLLEGE SCHOLARSHIPS TO OUR
LOCAL STUDENTS.
THOSE WHO KNEW HIM SAY IS
POSITIVITY.
WAS UNWAVERING AND SPREAD TO ALL
THOSE THAT KNEW HIM.
HIS STEADFAST SAYING UNITY IN
OUR COMMUNITY WILL CONTINUE TO
IMPACT THE RESIDENTS OF
BAKERSFIELD FOR YEARS TO COME.
AS THE FOUNDER OF HALL AND THEN
SERVICE INCORPORATED IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY ONE WILL ALSO BE
REMEMBERED AS A PIONEERING
MEMBER OF THE EMERGENCY MEDICAL
SERVICES COMMITTEE.
WE THANK HIM FOR HIS DEDICATED
SERVICE TO BOTH BAKERSFIELD AND
KERN COUNTY. HIS LEGACY LIVES ON
IN ALL THE LIVES HE IMPACTED
DURING HIS REMARKABLE YEARS WITH
US
PLEASE JOIN ME IN ADJOURNING IN
HIS MEMORY TODAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MR FUNG MISTER SAUCIER
RECOGNIZED FOR THE SAME
ADJOURNMENT.
THANK YOU MR SPEAKER MEMBERS I
ALSO RISE TO ADJOURN IN THE
MEMORY OF HER FORMER MAYOR MY
FRIEND. BAKER SPILLED.
MAYOR HARVEY HALL WHO IS ALSO
THE FOUNDER PAUL AMBULANCE BY
AMBULANCE.
IS A LOCAL AM.
SKIS ME.
SPEAKER.
MISTER HALL I JUST WANNA SAY WAS
A PERSONAL FRIEND AND SOMEONE
THAT I HAD THE PLEASURE OF
WORKING WITH. ON THE CITY
COUNCIL KNOWS FOR SELECTED TO
THE ACTUAL CITY COUNCIL. I'M
GOING TO TELL YOU MISTER HALL
WAS FULL OF LIFE FULL OF ENERGY.
HAD NOTHING BUT LOVE.
IN UNITY HIS IS FAVORITE PHRASE
WAS UNITY IN THE COMMUNITY. ME
WOULD BRING PEOPLE TOGETHER AND
THAT'S WHAT HE DID HE DIDN'T
REALLY.
CARE SO MUCH ABOUT YOUR
PARTISAN AFFILIATION.
HE DIDN'T CARE ABOUT.
WHAT SIDE OF THE RAILROAD
TRACKS YOU RUIN?
HE CARED ABOUT TRYING TO MAKE AN
IMPACT HAVING AN IMPACT ON THIS
COMMUNITY HAVING AN IMPACT ON
HIS EMPLOYEES AT ALL AMBULANCE
HIT HE CARED ABOUT THE IMPACT
THAT YOU MADE WITH OTHERS.
AND HOW YOU IMPACTED THEM AS A
PERSON.
AND I CAN TELL YOU THAT HE WILL
BE.
SORELY MISS.
SOMEBODY IN THE COMMUNITY THAT
WE ALL LOOKED UP TO NO MATTER
WHICH SIDE OF THE POLITICAL
SPECTRUM YOU. YOU SAT ON HE WAS.
ONE OF THOSE INDIVIDUALS THAT
THAT WE ALL ADMIRED BECAUSE HE
WOULD TAKE THE COURAGEOUS STAND.
TO. TO JUST
TO STAND UP FOR PEOPLE THAT.
THAT NEEDED A VOICE
AND I KNOW THAT'S WHAT I'LL.
.
REALLY MISS ABOUT MY DEAR FRIEND
AND I KNOW THE BIG FIELD
COMMUNITY. WILL WILL MISS HIM
DEARLY AND I RESPECT. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT THIS BODY
INJURED IN HIS MEMBER.
THANK YOU MISTER CELIS MR FUNG
YOU'RE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
SECOND A GERMAN IN ME.
I THANK YOU MR SPEAKER MEMBERS I
RISE TO JOIN IN THE MEMORY OF
THE HAS BEEN MAYOR AND GRIMES
WHO PASSED AWAY AT THE AGE OF
SEVENTY FIVE. MAYOR GRAHAM SPENT
SEVENTY YEARS OF HIS LIFE IS A
PROUD RESIDENT ATTACH BE.
HE SHOWED THAT DEDICATION TO
THIRTY FIVE YEARS OF SERVICE TO
THE CITY AND THREE TERMS AS
MAYOR.
TEHACHAPI IN MAJOR CRIMES WERE
SYNONYMOUS AS THERE WAS NO
GREATER ADVOCATE FOR THE TAX BE
COMMITTEE THEN MAYOR ED GRIMES.
WHILE IN OFFICE MILLIGRAMS ALSO
AS ALWAYS SERVED THE GOAL OF
IMPROVING THE QUALITY OF LIFE OF
THOSE INTENSITY FROM FIXING
STREET SIGNS TO BUILDING
HOSPITALS THERE WAS NO TASK TO
GREATER SMALL.
FRED.
KNOWN THROUGHOUT THE COMMUNITY
AS THE VOICE OF THE LAWYERS AS
PASSION FOR ANNOUNCING AT
TEHACHAPI HIGH SCHOOL FOOTBALL
GAMES WILL TRULY BE MISSED.
HIS LOVE OF THE CITY AND YOU
DETACH ME STEMMED FROM HIS
UPBRINGING IN FOSTER HOMES.
NO MATTER WHERE HE WAS MAYOR
GRIMES ALWAYS KNEW THAT TASK HE
WAS HOME.
IT'S PRESSING HIS COMMITMENT TO
THE STUDENTS ATTACHED BE MAYOR
GRIMES DONATED HIS ENTIRE
MAYORAL SALARY TO SCHOLARSHIPS
FOR TAX WE STUDENTS GOING TO
COLLEGE LEAVING A LASTING IMPACT
ON THEIR FUTURES.
AS A LEGACY OF SERVICE AND PURE
LOYALTY THE CITY ATTACH ME WILL
LIVE ON IN THE LIVES OF THOSE HE
TOUCHED.
I AM PROUD OF CALL THIS MAN A
MAN A FRIEND AND A MENTOR PLEASE
JOIN ME IN A DURING HIS MEMORY
TODAY.
THANK YOU SOME REMEMBER FUNG.
A SIMILAR EVER GALLAGHER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR ENJOYMENT.
THANK YOU MR SPEAKER MEMBERS
COLLEAGUES.
TODAY ASKED THAT WE ADJOURNED
IN MEMORY OF MELVIN JOHN
BOARDMAN.
MEL BOARDMAN.
HE WAS A MAN OF.
OF FAITH A MAN OF DUTY.
A MAN OF INTEGRITY.
YEAH HE PASSED UNEXPECTEDLY A
FEW WEEKS AGO AND I CAN TELL YOU
THAT.
HE IS.
BARELY SORELY MISSED BY THE
SAUCER COMMUNITIES IN WHICH HE
WAS SUCH AN INTEGRAL.
PART.
.
NO AND I BOTH GREW UP IN THE
SAME COMMUNITY.
.
WE KNOW GRADUATED FROM HIGH
SCHOOL.
NOW HE'S ALL OF ME I WENT TO
SCHOOL WITH HIS CHILDREN AND I
AND THAT WHAT I REMEMBER MOST
ABOUT MEL AS HE WAS ALWAYS VERY
PRESENT IN HIS CHILDREN'S LIVES
HE WAS.
ALWAYS VERY ACTIVE IN THE SCHOOL
HE WAS VERY ACTIVE IN A LOT OF
COMMUNITY EVENTS.
WHEN MEL GRADUATED FROM HIGH
SCHOOL HE WENT ON TO SERVE HIS
COUNTRY VERY HONORABLY.
IN THE ARMY.
AND WHEN HE CAME HOME.
A HE HAD TWO SURPRISES WAITING
FOR HIM.
ONE.
WAS HE FOUND THAT HIS YOUNGER
SISTER HAD WRECKED HIS PRIZE CAR
AFTER SCHOOL DRAG RACE.
AND SECOND.
AND MORE IMPORTANTLY HE MET.
AND FOUND THE LOVE OF HIS LIFE
CHARLOTTE. AND WHOM HE WOULD
RAISE CHILDREN WITHIN HIM HE
WOULD GOLD WITH THE FACT THEY
WERE MARRIED.
FORTY NINE YEARS.
AND YOU COULD ALWAYS COUNT ON.
MEL IN CHARLOTTE SHOWING UP TO
AN IMPORTANT COMMUNITY MEETING
AND I REMEMBER MANY TIMES.
SPEAKING WITH HIM TALKING WITH
HIM AND MELGES HAD A HE HAD A
WISDOM.
ABOUT SO MANY DIFFERENT THINGS
THEY WENT OUT AND WORKED VERY
HARD.
.
CAME BACK OUT OF THOSE FIELDS.
AND WOULD GO TO A SCHOOL BOARD
MEETING WOULD.
GO TO A BASKETBALL GAME.
NON.
WOULD ALWAYS BE THINKING ABOUT
HEY HOW CAN I GIVE BACK.
NON.
MEL IN CHARLOTTE RAISE FIVE
CHILDREN HAVE NINE
GRANDCHILDREN.
THEY HAVE ESTABLISHED A LEGACY
AND THAT CERTAINLY WILL NOT BE
FORGOTTEN.
IN OUR COMMUNITY AND TODAY I
ASK THAT.
WE JOIN CHARLOTTE THE FAMILY WE
SHARE AND THEIR LOSS.
AND WE ASK THAT. THIS BODY
INJURED IN THE MEMORY OF MELVIN.
JOHN BOARDMAN.
OUR HEARTS ARE BROKEN IN OUR
THOUGHTS ARE WITH HIS COMMUNITY
FRIENDS.
AND LOVED ONES THANK YOU
MEMBERS.
THANK YOU MISTER GALLAGHER
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MELINDA'S YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
COLLEAGUES I RISE TO DURING IN
THE MEMORY OF MAYOR NEIL
WINTERS.
HE SERVED AS MAYOR MENIFEE IN MY
DISTRICT ON HE UNEXPECTEDLY DIED
OF A HEART ATTACK LAST SATURDAY.
YOU WAS A LONG TIME RESIDENT OF
THE CITY OF MEN MENIFEE NAY
BECAME A PUBLIC FIGURE THROUGH
GRASSROOTS CAMPAIGNING AFTER
SPENDING MOST OF HIS LIFE AS A
TEACHER AND A SOFTWARE ENGINEER.
OUR EXECUTIVE EXCUSE ME.
I THINK MOST OF THE PEOPLE IN
MANY P. REMEMBER HIM THAT WAS
SPENDING MANY HOURS ON THE
CORNER CAMPAIGNING WAVING HIS
SIGNS BIG SMILE FOR EVERYONE WHO
WENT BY.
BUT HE WAS MUCH MORE THAT A
POLITICIAN AND A MAYOR OF
MENIFEE.
HE WEIGHS A VERY COMPASSIONATE
LEADER AND HE WAS ONE WHO
ENCOURAGED PEOPLE AND HE WAS A
PERSONAL FRIEND TO MANY.
IN OUR COMMUNITY AND HE CARED
VERY MUCH FOR THE POOREST INNER
CITY YOU CAN OFTEN FIND HIM OUT
TALKING WITH.
THE HOMELESS IN SEEING IF. IF
THERE'S ANYTHING HE COULD DO.
HELPING THEM TO FIND THE
SERVICES THAT THEY MIGHT NEED
ANNIE CERTAINLY COMPASSIONATE
MAN IN IT AND IT SHOWED. AND HE
WAS ALSO THE VOICE OF THE
AVERAGE JOE AT CITY COUNCIL
MEETINGS AND LEAD.
MOST MORE OFTEN THAN NOT FIND
SOLUTIONS TO SOME OF THE BIGGEST
PROBLEMS.
DIDN'T NECESSARILY CARE THAT IT
GOT HIM INTO TROUBLE WITH HIS
OWN COLLEAGUES.
ANY ALSO HAD KIND OF A WICKED
SENSE OF HUMOR I'M DURING HIS
CAMPAIGN.
NEIL WINTERS CAMPAIGN SLOGAN HE
STOLE SOMETHING FROM THE AYE
GAME OF THRONES IN HIS CAMPAIGN
SLOGAN WAS WINTERS COMING.
WHICH WE ALL THOUGHT WAS PRETTY
FUNNY.
AND HE LED WITH A SERVANT'S
HEART YOU TO CHIU CHAMPION OF
THE PEOPLE HE IS SURVIVED BY HIS
WIFE DEBBIE HIS CHILDREN LOGAN
AND NICOLE. AND IS GREEN
CHILDREN JADEN CALLIE AND WILL
MISS HIM DEEPLY AND MEMBERS ASK
THAT WE ADJOURN IN HIS MEMORY
THANK YOU.
pTHANK YOU MS MELENDEZ OUR
MEMBERS PLEASE BRING THE NAMES
OF TO THE DESK TO BE PRINTED IN
THE JOURNAL. ALL REQUESTS TO
JOIN A MEMBER WILL BE DEEMED
READ AND PRINTED IN THE JOURNAL.
ALL OTHER ITEMS REMAINING WILL
BE PASSED AND RETAINED ALL
MOTIONS SHALL BE CONTINUED. AS.
SEEN HEARING NO FURTHER.
BUSINESS I AM READY TO
ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO ADJOURN.
MS MELENDEZ.
.
MISTER COOPER MOVES TO HAVE MS
ELECT AS SECONDS.
.
THAT WE HAD STAND ADJOURNED
UNTIL THE AYE THIS HOUSE STANDS
ADJOURNED UNTIL TUESDAY MAY
TWENTY NINTH AT ONE PM.
WE'RE TURN